breaking news overnight in taiwan where
at least
48 people were killed in an early
morning train accident
around 70 other passengers were hurt in
the crash two hours north of the capital
of taipei lucycraft reports on the
rescue efforts that went on
for several hours this was the scene
moments after the deadliest rail
disaster in taiwan's history
a passenger train partially visible
wrecked on its way
into a tunnel survivors climbing out of
windows and onto the roofs of overturned
rail cars to reach safety
first responders treating the injured
while rescuers work to free others
still believed to be trapped inside
because there's no other way this
passenger said we had to climb to the
top of the train and then climb down
officials say the accident took place
when the packed eight-car train
carrying nearly 500 people smashed into
a truck
it's believed to have accidentally slid
onto the tracks
this passenger says i was sitting on the
isle side and i was thrown to the floor
the accident took place in a scenic area
at the start of the tomb sweeping day
holiday
with many passengers on their way to pay
their respects to deceased family
members
images taken at the scene show survivors
carrying luggage as they escape the
crumpled cars
the path in front of them now littered
with wreckage
for cbs this morning lucy craft tokyo